c'est bien dédicace à table basse à ce
que j'en ai un problème qui shoote
toujours in war c'est vrai mais ils
devront pas avoir ça en fait bienvenue
dans notre toute beauté ça il ya encore
un grand sur ma chaise je sais que mes
impôts dépenses que je suis petit nom en
plus pas tellement eu peu trop de
graisse pas fou
salut aujourd'hui je suis avec simon
simon le jeu vis des halles vous
connaissez pas et bien cliqué parce que
c'est cool avec six mois on se connaît
depuis à peu près le début d'année on a
lancé notre chaîne quasi en même temps
et on sait suivi on s'envoie des petits
messages et enfin on se voit pas ce que
tu étais à la paris games week
en fait les trucs de mentalist on note
un mythe jamais parce qu'ils savent pas
encore que j'existe bientôt jeudi à
tulle immortalisera tous est ce qu'on
l'a bien avec lui
donc toi de les spécialiser dans le jeu
vidéo sur ta chaine d'une manière
originale et c'est pour ça que j'ai
suivie depuis le départ on n'est pas sur
une chaîne typique gaming qu'est ce
qu'on peut retenir finalement une fois
qu'on a posé la manette qu'est ce que
j'ai retenu pourquoi je marque plus
tueur je veux pas jouer un peu au jeu
vidéo
faut que ça n'existe pas je peut que
perdre ma vie je mets entre deux chars
elles transforment en ahl tu sais que
les premiers jeux multijoueurs dont
dofus quoi ils jouent à l'office ouais
j'ai joué au fus nice ou ailleurs je
sais déjà aujourd'hui sion voilà c'était
la révolution pour ma d'office bomba
d'office j'ai pas vu le jour durant une
semaine quoi et je peux jouer allez on
va dire qu'à quelques jeux sur consoles
portables si possible étoiles ça mais
même avec un évident at une foule
nouveau élevé entre les mains tu le
beauf
bah je vais la voir jouer le beauf et ça
sortira pas de chez moi je suis pareil
quand j'ai un jeu je le sais n'y ont
donc mais mêmes mario cap [ __ ] de
mario kart que j'ai achetés sur la 3ds
l'amlin challenge
parfois je le mange et sa wii en deux
jours mais après il faut une fois une
fois toutes les étoiles
sinon ça va pas j'ai raté ma vie
haoues moi bah oui c'est son nom merci
pour cette thérapie
tu vas te placer ici et l'idée c'est que
je vis bouger autour de toi je t'ai dit
qu'il fallait que quand à venir tels
choisir un jeu vidéo dans ta tête
un maillot que je connais c'est ce que
nathan en tête c'est bon vous un jeu
vidéo que je connais tu connais c'est
sûr c'est sûr ok j'avais pas moyen de le
connaître c'est bon non je ne sais pas
tu as été mettre des micros chez moi
alors j'espère qu'il va se passer des
trucs chelous faut qu'ils fassent
confiance ok ok donc dix fermes les six
arbres métalliques le plus celle où la
carrière à paris c'est moi qui tu fermes
les yeux mais tu vas inspire à fond et
spigraph ça c'est juste pour se détendre
voilà tu vas juste des serrer les mains
non je peux faire c'est ainsi tu veux
c'est le genre de petits mouvements
sociaux bien détendu de temps en temps
tu mens entre un drap derrière ou sur ta
gauche ou devant toi ou sur ta droite
peu importe distance ok je vais te
demandait d'imaginer que tu plonges dans
ton jeu vidéo tu tombes
concrètement dans le jeu vidéo gens à
l'intérieur c'était plus en face de
l'écran tu es dedans
ok tu va regarder autour de toi ce qui
prend le temps de regarder et je suis
sentie s'il ya de l'action que tu te
sentes concernés par cette action si
c'est quelque chose où faut se
concentrer concentre toi mais essaye
vraiment de d'imaginer tout le décor du
jeu vidéo autour de toi super où je
crois garde bien les yeux bougent pas
que le suisse le franc lequel pas je me
prendre en photos et messages sur
twitter en place et c'est pas le petit
calepin là c'est le gros calepin tu
verra donc tu imagines tout le décor
autour de toi oh non
si c'est un jeu
multijoueur pape je m'expliquerai si
c'est un jeu où il ya plein d'unités par
exemple comme l'était command and
conquer les vrais s'arranger avec un
tueur imagine que tu es une de ses
unités là tu vois si c'est un jeu type e
zelda tu imagines que tellink vasculaire
toi quelqu'un continue de regarder
autour de toi ok je pense qu'on es tu
vas me confirmer ou infirmer ça je pense
qu'on est vraiment dans un décor comment
te dire dans un décors fixes 3d ou toi
tu peux évoluer un peu où tu veux est-ce
que c'est noël on est bon on n'est pas
sur une plateforme style mario
non ok et je pense donc que tu
représentes un personnage
ouais ok est ce que tu peux te sentir de
plus en plus dans la peau de ce
personnage là ok ça marche
ok tu es plutôt détendue et la position
de la prise est intéressante c'est à
dire que c'est la position du personnage
repos ok est-ce que ce personnage et des
objectifs où il a un objectif il ya un
objectif très précis
ouais ok ça marche et cet objectif pour
ça il faut aller le chercher et c'est
compliqué et c'est ça effectivement
c'est toujours qu'on parlait bien
cherché cet objectif
ok ah j'aime bien parce que tu bouges la
tête et tu regarde toujours à droite à
gauche qui se peut se passer les ennemis
qui peuvent arriver mais toute la
difficulté du jeu n'a pas l'air d'être
ici allez peut-être plus sur une
concentration une précision dans le jeu
je vais je vais écrire son nom dans quel
jeu tués d'après moi est-ce que sans
ouvrir les yeux tu peux me dire
donc je tu es dans ta tête tomb raider
tomb raider est ce que je peux ouvrir
les yeux fermés
en fait et tomates c'est pour ça quand
je me dis croit une région j'attends
c'est calme vachement sûrement un état
tout assure filles qui étaient ancrés
dans le sol
c'était hyper intéressant je te
recommande de regarder ta propre vidéo
elle parce que tu avoir oscillé des
mouvements oculaires derrière les
paupières tu vas voir la manière dont tu
réagis forcément vous derrière votre
écran même si vous suivez la chaîne vous
dites mais comment il a pu savoir je
vous le répète je garde une partie de la
popote pour moi et c'est comme ça que la
chaîne elle continuera aussi à vous
apprendre des choses au fur et à mesure
a été comme ça que je peux continuer à
vous bluffer et vous faire marrer en
spectacle ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une
auto promo temps je suis là c'est le
bleu c'est fait merci d'être venus
jusqu'à chez moi aussi parce que je veux
savoir quand même que c'est toi qui a
bougé mais oui le grand plaisir un de
ces quatres on va se faire une vidéo
aussi ensemble jeudi chez moi qui ce qui
fait partie de la série exactement à
quoi tu joues et le bull sait que fabien
va venir parler d'enjeux qui l'a
énormément marquée ont quelques points
et moi je donnerai un point de vue
global hills energy élargit sur
l'univers du jeu vidéo en fonction ce
qui me dira et c'est vraiment cool que
tu mets proposés sa merci à ce que l'on
connaît bien de quel juge par le met au
pas d'anciens on le garde
non mais un peu le johnny en des gars on
lui dit j'ai parlé civilisation le
fameux maria beaucoup de choses à dire
entre civilisations salle de travail que
j'ai commencé vraiment sur le premier
qui tenait sur deux disquettes et à
dénoncer changer les trucs pour le code
de rein dans l'es6 et une très grande
série à beaucoup de choses à dire et je
reçois encore aujourd'hui donc c'est
vraiment cool et si la vidéo vous a plu
vous pouvez nous faire savoir en
laissant un magnifique pouce en l'air
qui fait plaisir qui fait du bien vous
pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne c'est par ici avant de partir se
dote aussi par là et rendez vous demain
à 17h ciao
voilà